The desire to be free from the limits of the human experience is as old as our
first stories, we exist in an endless universe,
only bound by the laws of physics.
And yet our consciousness is trapped in mortal machines,
made of meat with the breathtaking explosion of innovation and
progress. For the first time,
the concept of leaving our flesh pals behind and uploading our minds
into a digital utopia seems possible even like the logical
next step on our evolutionary ladder,
mind uploading and digital immortality past some of the core themes of the games
cyberpunk 2077.
It plays in a grim dystopian future where humanity has progressed far beyond
today's technology and explores what this could mean for humanity.
About a year ago,
CD Projekt red asked us if we would like to make a video about some of these
ideas and we were immediately on board. So let's explore this topic together.
Is it possible to upload your mind into a computer? Well,
it's complicated.
[Inaudible].
Upload what exactly mind is.
One of those words that are really hard to define,
it's thought to be the collective abilities of your consciousness and
intelligence.
The thing that lets you imagine recognize and dream mind
uploading is the hypothetical concept of making a copy of this in a world and
transferring it into a computer to run a simulation of your consciousness.
But even defining the premise gets really hard, ready, fast.
The possibility of mind uploading is based on three assumptions.
Assumption one, your mind is in your brains structure,
arrangement, and biochemistry.
The idea that everything about the mind can be found in the brain is called
physicalism and it keeps out discussion within the domain of natural law
assumption two. At some point,
we will understand the brain well enough and possess the technology to simulate
all of its aspects, to make a digital mind. Copy assumption,
three computer software can host your mind,
which means the mind is computable.
There is no physical property in the brain,
including consciousness that cannot be simulated accurately.
Even if it requires a lot of code.
All of these assumptions have been proposed and challenged by scientists and
philosophers,
and they remain the subject of passionate debate with so many fundamental
questions. Still unanswered.
It's hard to discuss the topic without annoying someone,
whatever your position,
every discussion of mind upload has to begin with the brain.
The brain, in a nutshell,
the brain is the most biological structure known and deserves its own entire
video. So let's just take a brief look at it.
Around 100 billion neurons are communicating via 1 million billion
connections that are sending signals up to 1000 times each second,
which is one quadrillion events, every second of your waking life.
And it's not just neurons.
There are billions of supporting and immune cells of various types,
performing different jobs on a macro level,
the brain could be divided into sections with different roles from breathing and
heart rate to coordinating movement and involuntary reflexes.
The most developed parts,
the neocortex or the outermost layer of the brain hold memories.
Our ability to plan think and imagine hope and dream
where exactly the you part of the brain is situated is not entirely clear.
We know that areas like the [inaudible] cortex have the greatest influence on
our consciousness,
but also that several areas can network together to share tasks.
None of them can do alone. The brains building blocks are not exactly simple.
Either neurons are not just wires.
They alter and process information.
Signups is where signals are handed over from one neuron to the next contain
receptors. For hundreds of chemical signals,
opening them up to outside influence.
We have a basic understanding of how these work and we can accurately predict
their behavior at small scales,
but there's a lot more to the brain than just nerve signals.
Hormones play a huge role like serotonin, which affects our mood or histamine,
which helps us learn. The brain is influenced by our other parts too.
From heart nerves to gut bacteria.
What seemed like a very complicated system to begin with gets even more
complicated. The more we learn about it to get this worldly, interconnected,
massive cells and meat and chemicals into a computer.
We need a model that we can simulate in our digital world. Some sort of scam.
Unfortunately,
our scanning technology like FMR machines is not nearly good enough to attempt
such a thing, but there is a different method that seems very promising.
Cutting a brain into tiny slices and scanning them with a high resolution
electron microscope to create an accurate map of all the cells and connections.
In 2019.
Scientists successfully mapped to eight cubic millimeter of mouse brain,
roughly the size of a big grain of sand.
It contained 100,000 neurons with a billion signups is and four
kilometers of nerve fibers.
This grain of brain was cut into 25,000 slices.
Five electron microscopes ran continuously for five months,
collecting more than 100 billion images.
It took three months to assemble the images into a 3d model.
The completed dataset fills up 2 million gigabytes of cloud storage
to scan a whole human brain.
We would have to repeat this effort a million times,
which is much easier said than done,
even worse to correctly simulate a brain.
We might even have to map out much smaller building blocks to include the
billions of underlying proteins or even individual molecules that cause all the
behaviors we see at the cellular level,
which might produce more data than the capacity of all data storage on earth,
brain water,
to consciousness wine while all of these issues are annoying.
The real question is how we turn the static blueprint of the brain into an
active thing.
Even if we have a scan down to the level of signups is we need laws and rules
that animate the wiring diagram to endow this static structure with a life,
update it with the various laws of chemical binding of electrodynamics to
animate the simulation. So it becomes a dynamic active thing,
like a brain that exists from one microsecond to the next that can evolve in
time think, see, and act.
The reality is that we just don't know if this is possible to achieve.
If our technology can give rise to real minds,
it all hinges on the nature of the problem are the brain and mind
just complicated and a lot of work to figure out,
or are they complex in a way that we can't solve in the worst case?
Consciousness is more than the sum of the parts of the brain in a way that we
don't realize yet complex in a way that we can't solve by getting better
scans,
just having a list of the ingredients might not be enough to get a good
consciousness cake.
Right now we have a great starting point with tangible scientific results and an
end goal.
But the road to true simulation is unclear and requires a lot of innovation
and research
Schumann's have historically been horrible at predicting the pace of progress
in the best case.
It's just a matter of doing the work and finding the right solutions.
It might not be necessary to simulate every last cell down to the last atom.
Instead,
it may be possible to simplify elements into probabilistic models that could
match the behavior of the brain using a more manageable number of simpler
systems.
So we really don't know if we will ever understand our brain and consciousness
well enough to upload human minds,
but the science is real and worth pursuing. At the very least,
we will just learn a lot about ourselves and develop a bunch of new
technologies. If we succeed,
this might put mind uploading well within the capabilities of our rapidly
progressing computer technology.
The consequences for humanity and our future in this universe are vast,
creepy and amazing.
The copy successful mind uploading is functional
immortality unless damaged or deleted. You will continue to, to exist.
As long as the copy is stored somewhere. Of course,
the scan is corrupted in any of a myriad of ways.
Your mind might get interrupted too.
You might be in an eternity of pain or paranoia or having an endless psychotic
breakdown. The question,
if this digital mind is you opens another whole can of worms for now,
we'll just assume that your digital mind at least feels like it's you.
How would mind uploading change your outlook on life?
Will you feel safer knowing that death is not necessarily the end or
would you try to be super safe to avoid dying before your mind is uploaded?
If scanning technology does become advanced enough,
your biological and digital versions could co-exist,
you could help me each other out by making your biological lifespan more
enjoyable. And the future of the copy, more secure,
whatever happens your mind copy will begin a completely new life.
Once it opens their digital eyes for the first time having a functional body is
actually quite nice and you're pretty used to it. Food love,
pain and exhaustion. All of these things are parts of us that we must live with,
but in the end, they are the result of neurons firing in your brain.
So while you could decide to live in a simulated body,
it might be optional for a digital mind.
Falling in love might lose meaning if you can have it at the press of a button
instead, you might end up searching for new extraordinary experiences.
Walk on the surface of the sun,
speed up time to skip past a few boring mumps
experience, a simulation of the past.
Your perspectives and priorities will change.
As you continue to exist in this liberated form,
the longer digital minds exist,
eventually they will likely gain greater knowledge of themselves and inability
to change their own contacts.
This can be as simple as deleting a memory that bugs you.
You might change aspects of your personality, my grudges, addictions,
or laziness without the constraints of biology,
your abilities might move up as technology progresses while your priorities or
goals might become more and more foreign to your original brain.
If it's still alive,
waking up to the true potential of digital immortality will be gradual.
You can start projects that would take more than a lifetime to complete
scientists could accumulate an incredible amount of knowledge leading to
discoveries that could revolutionize the world.
Adventurers could upload themselves onto small spaceships and embark on journeys
to the stars. Just putting themselves on pause for thousands of years at a time.
Although it's unlikely that every digital mind will work for the benefit of
humanity. Since our current meet versions,
don't do that either some will seek power and influence and we'll have a literal
eternity of trying to create empires.
Others will begin hoarding as many resources for themselves as possible as they
compete with other minds trying to do the same, the longer they live,
the less sympathy they may feel for simple meet beings or imagine
immortal current leaders who propagate lies and invent religions
fine-tuning and perfecting their dogma over hundreds of years,
or perhaps none of all that maybe our minds are not made for
immortality and digital minds will just become rigid and unproductive
and retire. After a very long life,
having experienced to everything they could ever want to.
It's hard to predict how much good or bad a self-improving mind could do
with hundreds or thousands of years of free time.
While.
Mind upload with all its wonders and Horace is beyond our current technological
capabilities.
You can use some of your free time in the present and experience one
interpretation of this future right away by hitting the streets of night city in
cyberpunk 2077,
cyberpunk 2077 is made by CD Projekt red.
The studio that brought us the Witcher series and is one of the most eagerly
awaited games of the last few years.
You dive into a dark dystopian future where incredible technology is redefining
who and what we are.
You can become part of this stunningly large world with immersive storytelling.
Here's the thing we haven't played the game yet, but when you see this video,
we're probably already doing so if the past work of city project red is any
indication, then this will be an amazing game,
which is why we did this collaboration and sat on this video for far too long.
So if it's made you curious, check it out.